hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live 5 Jahre und drei Monate so lautet
das Urteil gegen die linksextremistin
Lina e unter anderem wegen
Mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen
Vereinigung das hat das
Oberlandesgericht Dresden heute
entschieden mit angeklagt waren auch
zwei Männer sie erhielten Haftstrafen
zwischen zwei Jahren und 5 Monaten sowie
drei Jahren und 3 Monaten die
Bundesanwaltschaft hatte den Angeklagten
vorgeworfen Leute aus der rechten Szene
Portal zusammengeschlagen zu haben und
Lina eh sie soll der Kopf der Gruppe
gewesen sein die hart ist das Urteil
gegen Lina eh das wollen wir heute mit
euch hier im Livestream besprechen ihr
könnt dazu Fragen stellen direkt im
Stream oder auch per Mail mit
kommentieren und schauen wir erstmal
gemeinsam und um uns alle auf einen
Wissensstand zu bringen auf eine
Übersicht dieses Urteils dieses Tages
ein Bericht von Franziska Wunderlich und
von Steffi Moritz Müller
wie ein Star wird Lina e von ihren
Anhängern bejubelt und beklatscht als
sie den Sitzungssaal betritt nach 97
Verhandlungstagen fällt der Richter am
Morgen sein Urteil fünf Jahre und drei
Monate Haft für Lina e zwischen knapp
zweieinhalb und dreieinhalb Jahren für
die mit angeklagtten der Richter saß als
erwiesen dass Lina e Mitglied einer
kriminellen Vereinigung war die
systematisch Jagd auf rechtsextreme
machte zwischen Oktober 2018 und Februar
2020 verletzte die Gruppe um Lina e 13
Menschen in Sachsen und Thüringen so
schlugen sie einen Bekannten Neonazi aus
Wurzen krankenhausreif eine anderen
Person brachen sie Jochbein und
Schädelknochen die Überfälle waren
geplant und eine Art Vergeltungsschlag
nach rechten Übergriffen diese
radikalisierungs- und Gewaltspirale darf
sich nicht weiter steigern unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden haben die
gewaltbereiten linksextremistischen
Szenen genau im Blick und werden weiter
konsequent handeln in einem
demokratischen Rechtsstaat darf es
keinen Raum für Selbstjustiz geben die
Staatsanwaltschaft hatte sogar acht
Jahre Felina eh gefordert doch die
Beweiskette war brüchig Aussagen waren
widersprüchlich die Verteidigung
plädierte auf Freispruch den wollten
auch die Anhänger der linken Szene und
haben bereits massive Proteste
angekündigt bis hin zur Androhung von
Gewalt und Zerstörung
unsere Reporterin Steffi Moritz Möller
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet sie ist live
dabei gewesen heute den ganzen Tag im
Gerichtssaal bei der Urteilsverkündung
die läuft auch immer noch zur Stunde
Steffi schön dass du bei uns bist hallo
hallo Steffi die Verhandlung
entschuldige ich frage auch direkt nach
weil das war heute ja ein spannender Tag
über Stunden und die Verhandlung die
musste auch zwischendrin sogar wegen
Tumulten unterbrochen werden was ist
passiert
ja du sagtest ist schon die
Urteilsverkündung läuft lange also die
Verkündung begann gleich heute früh um
zehn die war relativ schnell erledigt
aber was dann folgte ist ein ellenlanger
Ritt der Urteils Begründung und es läuft
immer noch und man geht von ungefähr
anderthalb bis zwei Stunden aus bis
diese auch beendet ist und man weiß
nicht ob es dann wieder lautstarke
Tumult gibt wenn die Angeklagten oder
Verurteilten waren den Saal verlassen
denn das was heute hier passiert da war
schon wirklich ein sehr lautstarker
Protest der linken Szene die ungefähr
zwei Drittel des Zuschauer Saales auch
in anspruchnahmen das begann schon heute
früh drei der Angeklagten betraten den
Saal unter riesigen applause und Füße
trampeln dann kam Lina eh allein in den
Saal und die würde wirklich wir haben es
gerade gehört wie ein Star gefeiert man
winkte sich zu es halten rufe wie halte
durch wir stehen zu dir das war alles
noch im Rahmen dessen was der Richter
gelten die aber als er dann die vier
Urteile verlesen hatte eskalierte die
Situation doch und die radikalen
Anhänger der Szene im Gerichtssaal
beleidigten die Richter und riefen also
hatten wirklich verbale Entgleisungen
und riefen
systemschweine klassenschweine
Fahrschule Freunde so dass der Richter
eingreifen musste und Sicherheitsleute
der Justiz diejenigen auch aus dem Saal
führten es wurde zum ersten Mal die
Verhandlung unterbrochen aber es war
natürlich nicht das letzte Mal es folgt
noch mehrere Male unter anderem als der
Richter auf die Begründung zu sprechen
kam warum man Diener eh auch verurteilte
bei dem Überfall auf den Wirt in
Thüringen es waren ja nicht nur so sechs
Straftaten gibt es ja nicht nur welche
in Sachsen sondern auch in Thüringen
und da rasteten einige Anhänger wieder
aus und riefen geht doch selber hin
Richter oder Beweis Umkehr und daraufhin
Schritten wieder die Sicherheitsleute
ein und eine derjenigen die den Saal
verlassen sollte ließ sich fallen und
daraufhin eskalierte die Situation es
mussten viele Sicherheitsbeamte anrücken
und es war erstmal eine lange Pause und
auf welche Beweise stützt sich das
Urteil was hast du heute gehört
naja zu allererst stützt man sich
natürlich auf die Zeugenaussagen zu
allererst natürlich auf die der
Opfer klar rechtsextreme aber auch auf
die Aussagen der Nachbarn die viel
mitbekommen haben und wo sich auch so
ein gewisses Schema herausgearbeitet hat
weil die Zeugenaussagen der Nachbarn ein
immer gleiches Prozedere beschrieben und
die immer gleiche weibliche Stimme
hörten zum Beispiel man stützt sich auf
DNA-Spuren auf andere Spuren auf
Indizien aber vor allem stützt man sich
auf die Aussagen eines Kronzeugen der
später hinzukam ja und zu dem Kronzeugen
gibt es sicherlich viel zu erzählen weil
ohne den Kronzeugen Johannes D ein
30-jähriger Mann aus Bayern der dann
übergesiedelt war nach Polen wäre der
Prozess wahrscheinlich nicht so
verlaufen wie er verlaufen ist da hat
der Verfassungsschutz eigentlich eine
ganz Schlaue Kante gezogen denn Johannes
D wurde von der linken Szene verstoßen
der ist nicht freiwillig ausge sondern
gegen ihn gab es den Vorwurf der
Vergewaltigung seiner Ex-Freundin
woraufhin ihn die linke Szene fallen
dies er ging nach Polen wollte dort
neues Leben anfangen als Erzieher und
eines Tages stand der Verfassungsschutz
vor der Tür und bat um eine
Zusammenarbeit er schlug ein und brachte
hier wirklich Fakten auf den Tisch die
die Richter Staunen ließen womit sie
nicht gerechnet hatten er gab hinter
männerpreis er gab namenpreis die der
kriminellenvereinigung mit angehörten
und vor allem belastete er die
Angeklagten denn er sagte klar Lina e
und ihr Verlobter der aber noch immer
untergetaucht ist sein der Hut dieser
Vereinigung würden Ziele und Ideen
bestimmen und der Prozess der lief ja
auch schon seit September 2021 dauerte
damit natürlich dann auch eine Weile war
es jetzt also der Kronzeuge den es
gebraucht hat um den Prozess auch zum
Ende zu bringen haben wir dich da
richtig verstanden hat ist deshalb dann
also auch diese Weile noch gedauert
also zumindest hat dieser Kronzeuge den
Prozess unerwartet lang in die Länge
gezogen aber er kam eben mit Fakten und
mit Beweisen womit man nicht gerechnet
hat und weshalb es zu dieser
Verurteilung kam der Richter hat den
Zeugen mehrfach nach seiner Motivation
gefragt das fand ich auch interessant
das wurde heute auch noch mal wieder
gespielt um dessen Glaubwürdigkeit zu
erklären hat er Geld bekommen gab es ein
Deal aber er konnte selbst auf die Frage
ist Richters angeblich nicht antworten
und hat gesagt nein er hat kein Geld
bekommen er kriegt genauso 1500 €, wie
vorher als Erzieher es gab auch keinen
Deal erkenne die Motivation eigentlich
selber nicht richtig er will einfach nur
ein Schlussstrich ziehen unter seinem
alten Leben das sei für ihn Motivation
genug und das war Überzeugung für die
Richter genug zu sagen er gilt für uns
als glaubwürdig
für heute sind sogar schon heute abend
Proteste der linken Szene in Leipzig
angekündigt aber auch am Samstag sollen
größere Proteste in Leipzig in Dresden
stattfinden was ist die dazu bekannt
soll das wirklich eine größere Sache
werden jetzt gerade hinter dir sieht's
ruhig aus vom Gericht wie ist die
Stimmung
ja ruhig ist es hinter mir weil halt die
Urteilsbegründung noch läuft rechts
neben mir das sieht man jetzt nicht war
die linke Szene den ganzen Tag unterwegs
man hört auch noch ein bisschen aber sie
scheinen nicht so einen langen Atem zu
haben wie ihre vier Angeklagten bzw
Verurteilten im Gerichtssaal die
brauchen noch eine ganze Weile aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist hier schon ganz
klar geworden wie der Samstag wohl
aussehen könnte in Leipzig die Demo ist
inzwischen angemeldet es werden ungefähr
4000 Anhänger erwartet Leipzig ist ja
auch ein Zentrum der linken Szene aber
aus ganz Deutschland sollen sie kommen
und keiner geht wohl davon aus dass dies
ein friedliche Abend in Leipzig werden
wird wir sind dabei wir sind gespannt
aber man hat heute schon gesehen wie die
Meinungen hier Aufeinandertreffen wie
lautstark Tumulte eskalieren ich glaube
nicht dass wir am Samstag von einer
friedlichen Demo berichten können
du wirst das Ganze für uns weiter
beobachten auch heute abend eben sind
schon Demos angemeldet worden ihr im
Studio Dresden beobachtet das Ganze
weiter vielen Dank jetzt erstmal für die
Einschätzung Steffi Moritz Müller
und wir können jetzt hier in dieser
Sendung noch weiter sprechen und ich
schaue auch gleich mal in den Chat auf
eure Kommentare und Fragen denn wir
werden jetzt erstmal uns der
juristischen Einordnung zuwenden haben
uns einen Gast eingeladen es ist
Professor Dr Sönke Florian Gerhold er
ist Strafrechtler an der Uni Bremen und
jetzt bei uns hallo schönen guten Tag
Herr Professor Gerhold schönen guten Tag
Herr Professor Gerhold wir haben ja eben
schon einiges gehört viele Schilderungen
des Tages was natürlich jetzt noch fehlt
ist die
Urteilsbegründung die liegt uns
schriftlich nicht vor deswegen können
wir jetzt natürlich auch nur so weit
sprechen aber das wollen wir jetzt gerne
tun ein Punkt der vielleicht ganz
spannend ist die Bundesanwaltschaft die
hat den Fall übernommen die forderte
sogar acht Jahre Haft für die Angeklagte
es ist der erste Fall so habe ich
gelesen heute auch es ist der erste Fall
eben gegen linksextreme seit Jahrzehnten
bei der der Generalbundesanwalt
überhaupt ermittelt also können Sie uns
das vielleicht mal erklären wann
passiert das überhaupt dass die
Bundesanwaltschaft damit rein geht
das kann ich Ihnen gerne erklären das
ist in den Fällen eines sogenannten
startschutz Deliktes der Fall und das
ist im Gerichtsverfassungsgesetz
geregelt es gibt einen bestimmten
Katalog an Straftaten in denen die
generell Bundesanwaltschaft entweder die
Verfolgung übernehmen muss oder
übernehmen darf wenn der Fall eine
besondere Bedeutung hat und ebenfalls im
Gesetz geregelt ist das eine besondere
Bedeutung des Falls dann anzunehmen ist
wenn sich die Tat über mehrere
Bundesländer erstreckt und das hat mir
gerade schon in der Anmoderation gesehen
dass wir hier der Fall ist man hat
mindestens zwei Bundesländer betroffen
und aus diesem Grund kann dann die
generell Bundesanwaltschaft das
Verfahren an sich ziehen auch wenn es
nur um die Bildung einer
kriminellenvereinigung geht und das
Verfahren vor dem Oberlandesgericht und
hat vor dem Staatsschutz hat anklagen
wir haben einige Kommentare jetzt im
Stream ich lese gleich mal ein paar vor
da geht's jetzt um das Strafmaß also das
was da jetzt verkündet wurde was also
den Angeklagten jetzt droht nach Urteil
Michael Melzer z.B kommentiert bei
Youtube hätte mindestens zehn Jahre
einwandern müssen so hier die Wortwahl
von Herrn Mälzer und hier schreibt er
Loko 182 bei Youtube nur
Körperverletzungen muss bestraft werden
ganz klar aber fünf Jahre sind absolut
lächerlich also was würden Sie sagen
wenn Sie uns das auch mal erklären wie
kommt denn so ein Strafmaß überhaupt
zusammen wir können uns das vorstellen
zunächst muss man gucken welche Delikte
den Strafrahmen bestimmen so nennt man
das also den Bereich innerhalb dessen
das Gericht die Strafe festsetzen kann
und bei einer gefährlichen
Körperverletzung reicht dieser
Strafrahmen von sechs Monaten bis zu
zehn Jahren immerhin in der Diskussion
waren ja auch noch andere Straftaten wir
wissen eben noch nicht wegen was jetzt
die Angeklagten genau verurteilt worden
sind aber unter anderem auch eine also
den Medienberichten zu folgen ein
räuberischer Diebstahl da wäre der
Strafraum z.B ein Jahr bis zu 10 Jahren
bis zu 15 Jahren sogar und das heißt die
verhängte Strafe würde schon für eine
einzelne gefährliche Körperverletzung
mitten im Strafraum liegen wenn wir
viele Taten haben also taten Mehrheit
haben dürfte sogar der Strafraum
nach oben überschritten werden das heißt
in diesem Fall hätte bis zu 15 Jahre
Haft gedroht weil es mehr als eine
gefährliche Körperverletzung waren und
man sagt ein durchschnittsfall liegt
ungefähr im ersten Drittel das heißt
ein Fall wäre wahrscheinlich unter fünf
Jahren geblieben aber wir haben hier
insgesamt 13 verletzte und sechs Taten
und dann noch alle möglichen Delikte wo
wir jetzt noch nicht genau wissen wegen
welcher sie verurteilt worden ist und in
der Summe ist dann eine Gesamtstrafe von
fünf Jahren und drei Monaten auf jeden
Fall nicht außerhalb des Rahmens den man
erwarten kann der unterschiedliche
Strafrahmen da habe ich auch Kritik
heute viel im Netz dazu gesehen wir
schauen auch gleich mal zusammen auf
einen Tweet also der Vorwurf den ich da
häufiger gelesen habe war das Sachsens
Ermittler eben härter oder nicht mit
gleicher Härte das war der Vorwurf gegen
rechte Schlägertrupps Vorgehen schauen
wir aber eben auch mal auf einen Tweet
jetzt von einem Kollegen das ist der
Journalist Christian Fuchs der schreibt
hier bei Twitter nennt ein Beispiel und
zwar André e also ein Angeklagter aus
einem anderen Verfahren bekam 14 Jahre
lang oder hat 14 Jahre lang
terroristische rechtsextreme Vereinigung
in Sachsen unterstützt die zehn Menschen
umgebracht hat da lautete dann das
Urteil zwei Jahre sechs Monate Haft und
jetzt hier der Vergleich mit Jonathan m
das ist der mit Angeklagte aus dem
Verfahren von heute kriminelle
linksextreme Vereinigung in Sachsen
unterstützt die niemanden umgebracht hat
Urteil drei Jahre drei Monate wie kommt
das denn dann zustande also oder wie
wird das gerechtfertigt so ein
unterschiedlicher Strafrahmen das ist ja
jetzt hier gerade der Vorwurf also gegen
Linke geht mein härter vor als
Gegenrecht
genau also der Inhalt des Strafrahmens
muss das Gericht eine sogenannte
Strafzumessung vornehmen das bedeutet
sie muss das Gericht muss alle Umstände
die für den Täter oder gegen den Täter
sprechen gegeneinander abwägen und dazu
zählen solche Umstände die gab es eine
geständige Einlassung dazu zählt ist
Reue sichtbar dazu zählt die schwere zum
Beispiel der Verletzungen die dann die
Personen erlitten haben dazu zählt alles
was eben die Rechtsgüter irgendeiner
Person verletzt hat und was vielleicht
das Unrecht auf irgendeine Art und Weise
oder die schultertäter gemindert hat
ganz wichtig ist eben auch war man
selbst Täter weil man vielleicht nur
Teilnehmer sind also ganz viele
verschiedene Umstände die das Gericht
hier einzubeziehen hat und wo sie dann
innerhalb des Strafraums die genaue
Strafe für diese Verfahren festlegen
muss und das lässt sich deswegen eben
schwer vergleichen
wenn man die Fakten des Einzelnen falls
nicht kennt
es gibt jetzt weitere Fragen da geht es
dann jetzt darum wie lange wird denn
überhaupt die Angeklagte ins Gefängnis
müssen die Verurteilte ins Gefängnis
müssen Sven Odenwald der User schreibt
bei Facebook wie viel netto
Freiheitsstrafe sind dann noch übrig
wenn die haftstraße 5 Jahre betreffen
soll das Verfahren schon zwei Jahre
gedauert hat und es ja auch schon Zeit
vergangen sein dürfte bis Anklage
erhoben werden konnte wie lange wird
denn Lina eh dann überhaupt jetzt in
Haft müssen
also die Untersuchungshaft wird auf
jeden Fall vollständig angerechnet das
heißt wenn Sie die zwei Jahre des
Verfahrens übers schon Untersuchungshaft
gesessen hat dann kann man die schon mal
abziehen die Zeit die die Anklage oder
die Ermittlung gedauert hat die kann man
nicht abziehen sondern hier ist nur zu
berücksichtigen wenn die Ermittlung
übertrieben lange gedauert haben wer
seine rechtsstaatswidrige
Verfahrensverzögerung haben dann muss
das bei der Strafzumessung durch das
Gericht berücksichtigt werden das muss
dann entweder wenn abgezogen werden oder
auf jeden Fall festgestellt werden das
zu lange gedauert hat da haben wir hier
erstmal keine Anhaltspunkte für das
Leben so gewesen sein könnte das heißt
die Untersuchungshaft wird vollständig
abgezogen und dann gibt es verschiedene
Möglichkeiten eben auch vielleicht
vorzeitig entlassen zu werden
wie lange ist dann jetzt im Ergebnis
noch sein wird das kann ich hier jetzt
nicht für Sie ausrechnen aber auf jeden
Fall kann ich Ihnen sagen die
Untersuchungshaft Zeit die wird schon
abgezogen ich habe auch noch eine Frage
gesehen da hat sich ein User eine Userin
gefragt ob denn aber jetzt die
Verurteilten überhaupt noch etwas tun
können also können die jetzt aber noch
dagegen vorgehen gegen das Urteil das
gesprochen wurde etwas daran noch ändern
ja das können Sie sie können Revision
einlegen und ähm mit der Revision dann
eben versuchen die Aufhebung dieses
oberlandesgerichtlichen Urteil ist zu
bewirken wie die Chancen dafür stehen
kann man erst sagen wenn man die
schriftlichen Urteilsgründe zur
Verfügung hat und die mit den können wir
auch heute nicht mehr Rechten heute
werden einfach die möglichkeitsgründe
verkündet die schriftlichen unter es
könnte liegen dann frühestens in ein
paar Wochen
dann werden wir also alle ganz gespannt
auf die schriftliche Urteilsbegründung
warten und dann natürlich auch von ihnen
den ganzen juristischen Experten
bestimmt dazu etwas online lesen können
ich sage jetzt erstmal an dieser Stelle
vielen Dank Prof dr Sönke Florian
Gerhold danke dass Sie bei uns waren
sehr gerne einen schönen Abend für alle
danke schön auch für Sie
damit ist natürlich jetzt für uns
zumindest was diese juristische
Einordnung anbelangt erstmal die Grenze
gesetzt wir haben einfach dieses
schriftliche Urteil noch nicht aber wir
können trotzdem hier in dieser Sendung
jetzt gerne noch ein bisschen weiter
vertiefen ich habe nämlich ein paar
Kommentare von euch auch gesehen dazu
und zwar über Extremismus ganz im
allgemeinen sprechen und auch über die
Unterschiede die ist dagegen könnte und
wir haben uns eingeladen dazu Hendrik
Hansen Professor Dr Hendrik Hansen er
ist Extremismus Forscher von der
Hochschule des Bundes für öffentliche
Verwaltung schön dass Sie bei uns zu
Gast sind hallo guten Tag
ich bin gerade übrigens weil ich habe so
viele Kommentare gelesen ich versuche
die gerade zu sortieren überlege gerade
wo wir am besten damit anfangen ich
steig mal ein am besten mit einem
Kommentar ich habe hier von susun bei
Youtube gelesen er oder sie schreibt
wenn man in wenn man in Dresden auf dem
rechten Auge blind ist muss man auf dem
linken etwas schärfer sein das ist
natürlich ein bisschen ironisch
formuliert dieser Kommentar oder ein
bisschen zynisch formuliert und eine
weitere User Frank Butcher schrieb bei
Facebook ich sage ja schon immer der
Staat darf auf keinem Auge blind sein
Extremisten egal welcher politischer
Couleur haben in einer Demokratie nichts
verloren
sprechen wir vielleicht mal darüber wenn
wir jetzt erstmal auf die linke Szene
eingehen wo er auch dieser Prozess jetzt
hier eben große Wellen geschlagen hat
sehen Sie dass es da eine Veränderung
gab innerhalb der linken Szene eine
krassere Radikalisierung in den letzten
Jahren wie schätzen Sie das ein ja das
kann man ganz deutlich feststellen diese
Radikalisierung in der
linksextremistischen Szene was man sehen
kann ist dass wir über viele Jahre
hinweg so die klassischen
Ausschreitungen hatten von autonomen wie
beispielsweise beim G20 Gipfel dieser
Ausschreitung waren natürlich schlimm
genug aber was wir jetzt beobachten
können ist dass das landestine Gruppen
gibt Gruppen die also im Verborgenen
agieren die gegen Rechtsextremisten
vorgehen bzw gegen solche Personen die
sie für Rechtsextremisten halten es war
ja einer dabei in Leipzig der war gar
kein Rechtsextremist der Druck nur eine
falsche Mütze beim falschen Symbol der
einem Secondhandladen gekauft hatte und
diese Leute werden dann verfolgt die
werden brutal zusammengeschlagen und
diese Gewalttaten sind systematisch
geplant also das sind nicht dass da
handelt es sich nicht um den
Zusammenprall von zwei Gewalttätern
sondern hier werden die Gewalttaten
systematisch im Vorhinein geplant von
den Angreifern und die sind auch
trainiert mit Kampfsport und auf diese
Weise kommt es dann zu schweren
Gewalttaten und das hat das eine andere
Qualität in der Tat als Ausschreitungen
der autonomen Szene wie wir sie eben in
der Vergangenheit gekannt haben
ich möchte gern noch einen weiteren
Tweet zeigen ich habe ja gesagt das gab
so unterschiedlichste Stimmen heute auch
bei Twitter viel Kritik auch der
Bundessprecher der Grünen Jugend der
hatte sich geäußert in einem Tweet
schauen wir mal kurz zusammen rein und
zwar kommentiert er hier Deutschland
2023 Durchsuchungen und fragwürdige
Ermittlungen gegen friedliche
klimaaktivistinnen skandalöses Urteil
gegen Lina eh währenddessen 600 Nazis
werden verhaft Befehl gesucht Party in
Sachsen mit Hakenkreuzflagge
Reichsbürger verübt Anschlag auf
Rettungskräfte
wenn da jetzt in dem Falle der
Bundessprecher der Grünen Jugend und
natürlich auch noch viele andere
Userinnen und User habe ich heute
gesehen so etwas schreiben woher kommt
das denn dass das aber auf jeden Fall
ein Teil der Öffentlichkeit so wahrnimmt
dass da härter gegen links als gegen
Rechts vorgegangen wird
ja der Hintergrund ist dass man bei
Linksextremisten davon ausgeht dass das
doch Leute sind die eigentlich das Gute
wollen und sich vielleicht lediglich in
der Wahl der Mittel vergreifen also
nämlich dass sie gewalttätige Mittel
anwenden während bei Rechtsextremisten
davon ausgegangen wird dass sowieso
schon die
dass die Ziele falsch sind und die
Mittel die sie anwenden und da wird also
insofern mit zweierlei Maß gemessen denn
es wird übersehen dass die
Linksextremisten um die ist hier geht ja
auch die Vorstellung haben dass sie eine
andere Republik wollen die wollen diesen
Staat bekämpfen mit jeder Gewalthandlung
die wir hier erlebt haben in der
Vergangenheit bei jeder dieser
Gewalthandlung handelt es sich ja um
Taten mit denen auch der Rechtsstaat mit
Füßen getreten wird also es war nicht
nur Angriffe gegen die Personen das war
ein Angriffe gegen den Rechtsstaat und
dann auf der anderen Seite muss man auch
sagen man kann das doch nicht
gegeneinander aufrechnen also die
Tatsache dass es auf der einen Seite
gewaltorientierte Reichsbürger gibt das
ist im letzten Jahr
zwei Festnahmen gab von ganzen Gruppen
von Gewalt von von Leuten die
Gewalttaten geplant hatten also im April
letzten Jahres diejenigen die Karl
Lauterbach entführen wollten den
Bundesgesundheitsminister und dann im
Dezember die Festnahmen von der Gruppe
um Prinz Heinrich den 13 prinzreuß
Heinrich den 13 diese diese Dinge kann
man doch nicht miteinander aufrechnen
und sagen weil wir diese Reichsbürger
haben dürfen können wir jetzt nicht
gegen Linksextremismus vorgehen sondern
man muss gegen alle Vorgehen die in
dieser Weise sich gegen unseren Staat
und gegen unsere verfassungsmäßige
Ordnung stellen das bedeutet ja auch
dass diese Leute die sich gegen unsere
verfassungsmäßige Ordnung stellen ja
auch die Meinungsfreiheit und die
Grundprinzipien unseres
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenlebens in
Frage stellen
nicht gegeneinander aufrechnen da sagen
sie natürlich etwas aber was natürlich
passiert ist ist werden Zahlen erhoben
also wir haben Vergleichszahlen wir
wollen mal gemeinsam auf Zahlen schauen
die hat das bundeskriminalamtamt erhoben
eine Statistik zur politisch motivierten
Kriminalität dabei nahm die Zahl der
links motivierten Straftaten von über
10.000 um 31% auf knapp 7000 ab und die
Zahl der rechtsextremistischen
Straftaten die legte von knapp 22.000
auf fast
23.500 zu das ist ein Plus von 7 %. das
sind natürlich zahlen die uns dann
zeigen dass es hier zumindest eine
erhöhte eine erhöhte gestiegene Zahl auf
der rechten Seite gibt wie passt das
dann zusammen mit auch jetzt zum
Beispiel der Aussage der
bundesinnenministerin die wir heute
gehört haben also sie sieht nämlich eine
zunehmende Gefahr durch linksextreme
Gewalttäter ich zitiere sie noch mal
ganz kurz in linksextremistischen
Gruppen sind Hemmschwellen gesunken
politische Gegner auch mit äußerster
Brutalität anzugreifen sagte sie im
demok automatischen Rechtsstaat darf es
keinen Raum für Selbstjustiz geben kein
zielrechtfertige politische Gewalt jetzt
haben wir aber die Zahlen gesehen wie
interpretieren sie diese Zahlen dann für
uns ja ich würde sagen das eine schließt
das andere nicht aus wir haben in der
Tat eine massive Gefährdung erstmal
überhaupt durch Islamismus da gab es ja
heute eine Reihe von Hausdurchsuchungen
auch in der bundesweit dann eine
Gefährdung durch Rechtsextremismus und
rechts Terrorismus und diese Gefahr
besteht diese Gefahr darf auch nicht
klein geredet werden und es gibt eine
Gefahr durch Linksextremismus und
vielleicht hier jetzt auch künftig von
links Terrorismus denn es ist ja eine
ein Teil der sogenannten
eisenacher-gruppe das sind ja diejenigen
ähm aus der Gruppe um Lina e Punkt die
noch
auf freien Fuß sind die mit Haftbefehl
gesucht werden die aber untergetaucht
sind und sich jetzt im Untergrund
radikalisieren könnten daraus kann eine
neue Form von links Terrorismus
entstehen und die Tatsache dass wir
jetzt darauf schauen heute bei wegen der
verkünd dieses Urteils in Dresden heißt
doch nicht dass wir von den anderen
Dingen wegschauen gerade in Sachsen da
hat ja ein Kommentar den sie zitiert
haben darauf hingewiesen wir haben in
Sachsen ein erhebliches Problem mit
Rechtsextremismus das kann ja gar nicht
geleugnet werden und das muss auch
angegangen werden aber eben sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen heißt ja nicht dass
man dann das andere nicht tut
insbesondere wo ihr die Gruppe um Lina
e-punkt ihre Gewalt gerade mit dem Kampf
gegen Rechtsextremismus rechtfertigt
aber dieser Kampf kann doch nie so
aussehen dass wir selber zum Schlagstock
greifen und diese Leute dann also
schwerst verletzen so dass sie bleibende
Schäden haben physische und natürlich
auch psychische Schäden und da geht's
nicht um Mitleid mit Leuten die Gewalt
orientierte Rechtsextremisten sind es
geht einfach darum dass das keine Mitte
sein können im Rechtsstaat und deshalb
kann ich nur daran appellieren also das
eine mit dem anderen nicht aufzurechnen
sondern Aufgabe des Rechtsstaates ist es
dass sich mit allen Varianten des
Extremismus gleichermaßen
auseinandersetzt ein User möchte gerne
wissen ich weiß nicht ob sie uns dazu
mehr sagen können weil es war jetzt das
Bundeskriminalamt dass die Zahlen
erhoben hat aber Uwe gödan fragt welche
Straftaten werden als rechte Straftaten
gezählt ja da ist ein wichtiger Punkt
jetzt weiß ich nicht welche also bei den
Straftaten da muss man immer
unterscheiden es gibt die sogenannten
Propaganda Delikte beim im Bereich des
Rechtsextremismus und jetzt weiß ich
nicht ob bei den Zahlen die Sie gerade
gezeigt haben weil ich jetzt die hier
die Zahlen gerade nicht vorliegen habe
ich vermute dass die dabei sind weil sie
doppelt so hoch waren wie die Zahlen für
den nächsten Extremismus Propaganda
Delikte gibt es nur im Rechtsextremismus
das möchte also zum Beispiel das zeigen
einer hakenkreuzfahrt oder eine
hakenkreuzschmiere rein das ein
Propaganda liegt wenn sie roten Stern
irgendwohin war ja als Zeichen für
Kommunismus das ist keine Straftat und
insofern wird das wird das nicht als
solche verfolgt und auf diese Weise gibt
es dann immer automatisch eine höhere
Zahl an Straftaten im Bereich des der
rechtsextremistischen politischen
motivierten Kriminalität als beim
Linksextremismus und man muss diese
erstmal rausrechnen bevor man dann die
Vergleiche durchführt und insofern ist
es in der Tat relevant dann genau auf
die Art der Straftaten zu gucken und da
ergibt sich jetzt in der im Schnitt dass
die Zahl der linksextremistisch
motivierten Gewalttaten regelmäßig
ungefähr auf dem Niveau ist von
rechtsextremistischen Gewalttaten aber
auch da wenn sie niedriger werden das
würde ja nichts an dem Grundprinzip
ändern das grundsätzlich solche Arten
von Gewalttaten nicht akzeptabel sind
und trotzdem bleiben so ein paar Fragen
bei uns im Chat im Stream zum Beispiel
wie die von Bennet Evergreen der oder ja
der sich fragt warum ist der
Verfassungsschutz so schlecht wenn es um
rechtsextreme geht also da herrscht wohl
auch wieder das Gefühl dass da eben in
Richtung links härter stärker verfolgt
wird als Richtung rechts also erst
einmal ich würde das erstmal so nicht
bestätigen dass der Verfassungsschutz
schlecht ist in der Bekämpfung von
Rechtsextremismus
schauen Sie sich die Fälle im letzten
Jahr an wir haben die Aufdeckung der
geplanten Entführung von dem
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach wir hatten die Aufdeckung der
Gruppe im Dezember 2020 diese große
reichsbürgergruppe die da aufgedeckt
wurde offensichtlich ist der
Verfassungsschutz da nicht so schlecht
aufgestellt wir hatten auch die
Festnahme von Leon R Punkt Leon er in
Eisenach der ja eines der
Opfer war von Lina eh und der wurde dann
im April letzten Jahres auch
festgenommen wegen mehrerer schwerer
Delikte auch Vorbereitung von rechts der
russischen Straftaten also was der User
im wohl im Blick hat der Kommentator im
Blick hat ist doch folgendes wir haben
immer noch diesen diese Geschichte von
von der nicht Aufdeckung des NSU und das
hängt natürlich dem Verfassungsschutz
nach das ist auch nachvollziehbar das
also dass die Leute beim
Verfassungsschutz dann auch an diese
diese Sache denken die nicht auf Deckung
des NSU es gibt andere Fälle an dieser
anderen Attentate Hanau und Halle im
Jahr 2019 in Oktober 2019 in Halle
Stefan Barriere und dann in Hanau im
Februar 2020 das waren rechtster
russische Anschläge die vom
Verfassungsschutz nicht im Vorhinein
verhindert worden sind allerdings muss
man da sagen dass man es mit einer
Gruppe mit Eltern zu tun hatte die man
nur sehr schwer im Vorhinein überhaupt
erkennen kann das waren Leute die sich
im Internet radikalisiert haben die ihre
Taten alleine geplant haben sie haben
sie waren vernetzt über das Internet mit
insbesondere bei Jever vernetzt mit
anderen Rechtsextremisten aber der ist
nicht auffällig geworden und wir haben
etliche Leute die so im Internet
unterwegs sind ähnliche Sachen machen
wie der Barriere und das leider Gottes
passiert ist einfach dass solche Leute
dann den Sicherheitsbehörden dann salopp
formuliert durch die Lappen gehen das
heißt aber nicht dass der
Verfassungsschutz schlechte Arbeit macht
sondern das heißt nur dass es dann eben
Fälle gibt die einfach sehr schwer
verhindert hätten verhindert werden
können also die Frage zum Schluss was
für unsere Gesellschaft gefährlicher ist
der Linksextremismus der
Rechtsextremismus das lässt sich gar
nicht beantworten würden Sie sagen ich
würde eine Rangfolge machen ich würde
schon sagen wir haben ein allererster
Stelle den Islamismus weil der auch am
stärksten international vernetzt ist wir
haben dann den Rechtsextremismus wir
haben hier erhebliche Gefährdungen im
Bereich des Rechts Tourismus wir haben
immer jüngere Täter im Bereich des
Rechtsterrorismus und dann die ganzen
Entwicklungen im Rechtsextremismus die
ich hier jetzt gar nicht alle aufzählen
kann und dann haben wir aber eben auch
den Linksextremismus und ich glaube das
ganz entscheidende ist dass wir die die
verschiedenen Bereiche nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen man kann das
Vergleichen man kann eine Rangfolge
machen aber man darf das nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen und schon gar
nicht
Linksextremismus legitimieren du aus der
Existenz von Rechtsextremismus heraus
das scheint mir das ganz entscheidende
zu sein denn dann kommt man in das
Fahrwasser dieser Antifa-Gruppen dort in
Leipzig die diese kleinen destin
Anschläge verübt haben sagt Professor Dr
Hendrik Hansen vielen Dank dass Sie bei
uns waren sehr gerne
und ich möchte die Sendung beenden mit
einem Kommentar von Jana Kugeln sie
schreibt bei Youtube Gewalt aus jedem
Grund ist keine Lösung dafür haben wir
Gesetze und eine Demokratie und ein
Prozess sonst kann man es direkt lassen
extremistisch und gewaltbereit ist immer
gefährlich und führt nie zufrieden und
Zusammenleben schreibt die Userin ich
hoffe das waren interessante Sendung für
euch ihr habt ein bisschen was mitnehmen
können ihr seid natürlich jetzt auch am
Wochenende zu den angekündigten
Protesten immer aktuell informiert bei
ZDF heute für heute ist bei uns Schluss
und bis dahin tschüss